you know going through our first feature
film one of the things I was most
important was finding locations before
writing the script I think that was a
huge deal because say a lot of times you
just want to write a script with you
know any locations of mine because you
want to die creativity just a flow but
then when you go after you writing the
script and go find the locations you
might have thought oh it'll be easy to
find you know some school that will
donate their weekends or something and
you're not anticipating that you finally
go to ask you know you're gonna
sweet-talk the principal and they're
like oh yeah no it's a thousand dollars
a day you know and you just had no idea
that that was gonna be part of the cost
so I think it was important you know
when you're about to write a script to
go oh well you know my mom has a beach
house and my uncle owns a grocery store
and you know so-and-so has a plot of
land and you find all these free
locations or cheap locations and then
you go from there and you write a script
around those locations that will
minimize your costs dramatically
when working with 13 days and like
$8,000 you are talking about just a few
hundred dollars a day that you have for
for everything you're doing and so
you're you're not you don't have time to
like do pickups you don't have time to
you know try to set up a shot once you
get there you need to make sure you know
exactly what you're going to be doing
that day so when we got to when I got to
finishing the script you know I'm an
illustrator that's what I did for a long
time comic books and children's books
and I did storyboards for movies and I I
saw the importance of getting the
storyboards down so that you when you
get to to the set you're not wasting
time
so I storyboarded the entire script from
you know the very first shot to the very
last shot and I knew it was gonna be
important but I didn't realize how
important it was till once we got there
so my first ad REM Mikan Berg was able
to open up the book look at the shot we
needed and say we need this shot and we
go okay let's set up the shot Dan RDP
set shot up sets lights up shoots it we
really do a red circle around that
what's the next shot here's the next
shot right here right in front of us
because we have the storyboards scripted
I mean Illustrated and that was far and
above a huge important piece of the
puzzle to get the movie done in time on
budget and and finished without having
to go back and go oh we we totally
forgot this shot and now we have to find
the location again and find the actors
again and set up this time we didn't
have to do that because we looked at the
script we looked at the storyboards we
had finished it all and I didn't expect
to walk into the first meeting of the
film and immediately know what the film
was gonna look like in the end which was
very important and now that I'm editing
the film
I don't really know what I would have
done without it because every time I go
into a scene the first thing I do is I
look at all the storyboards to get a
feeling for what Joe wants out of the
scene and knowing that having that
backbone that structure allows me to
kind of branch off of it and to build
off of it and to be more creative
because I can allocate more of my mind
and more of my time to to the little
details as opposed to the backbone
structure
I think the storyboards are one of the
most important parts of making sure this
film got made on time I mean we shot 90
pages in 13 days which was kind of
insane and I just remember the first
time we had that or we were presented
with storyboards I looked at this and
said this is gonna make my job a million
times easier I mean the movie was
basically already made and all all we
had to do was just get in there and
actually shoot it and even though we did
change up a few things here there at
least we still had the foundation of
everything already built so I was able
to see exactly what Joe wanted to make
and that made everybody's life 100 times
easier
I think that when you're shooting a film
for under 10,000 at least the way we did
bartering and and just and just
sweet-talking being nice and like
gaining relationships with people is
like number one because you're not going
to be able to pay everybody or pay very
many people at all or anybody and so you
have to learn to say like what are my
aspects or what are my talents that I
can give to other people that I can
trade with people like I'm an artist I'm
an illustrator so I was able to like
barter my illustration skills for other
people's skills
for me and this is one of the ways that
I approach this movie with Joe was I've
been on a few sets before where the
directors and 80s would get together and
they say okay we only have X amount of
hours left what scenes are we gonna cut
and that is something with this movie I
did not want to do at all when I sat
down and we went through the storyboards
I went through the script with Joe a lot
of it I mean it 99% of it was almost
pivotal of what he wanted and I said
okay I want to make sure I'm getting
whatever his vision is I am shooting it
I am making sure we get that done so I
don't say this happens all the time but
for this efficiency was greater than
creativity and not that you shouldn't
have both together but making sure that
we got everything we needed to do that
day that we need a wide we need medium
close-ups if this is it we do one take
we do to take max on just about
everything in the movie how do we make
sure we are not missing anything so I
make sure Joe is getting his full vision
out there then when we have time okay
great we finished this scene and I still
have 20 minutes left
what's a creative angle what else can we
do to enhance what we already have
because regardless of whether or not we
get more creative with it we can still
tell a story and at the end of the day
if you haven't shot something if you
spent an hour critiquing a shot trying
to move a sandwich one specific way or
you know fine-tune the details within a
shot you may not get the shot off and
you may be sacrificing other shots which
are more important but you won't know
that until you're on post so making sure
we get everything to me was what's most
important that's kind of how I how it
looked at this
a huge
as a creator is that you created this
piece of art and you you feel like this
is unchangeable like this is exactly
what you envisioned but when you're
working on a small budget with a
voluntary cast and crew like you don't
have the the the luxury of that kind of
rigid idea if you were working a 500
million dollar budget sure do it all day
long but when you well under $10,000
whatever you've got a no budget film
you've got to be willing to make
compromises to fit in the time
constraints to fit in the money and so
writing the script there was a lot of
things I had I had to after writing
script look back and go there's not
enough time for this there's not enough
money for this we're gonna have to
change the script and be able to work on
the fly and changing the script and it
if you're a good enough artist in a
creative enough you'll be able to do
that you know and that just tests your
merit as as an artist and there was a
lot of things on set that we had on the
fly go there's no way we can get this
shot like there was one shot we wanted I
wanted a real high aerial shot inside of
the inside of a warehouse it was gonna
be this nice like bird's-eye view of of
this control room and then once we got
there realized there's no way we could
do this and we don't have enough time to
set up the shot
anyway and so then we got another shot
we just set up a ladder and we shot as
high as we could and looked really great
and so you have to be willing to make
changes on this kind of a set
I think the biggest thing for a biggest
tip for writing a script when you're on
a very low budget is I wrote the script
with one main character one main actress
and everyone else was supporting roles
that way
I had one actor that had to commit the
entire time and everyone else only
needed to commit to one or two days and
that worked out great because it reduced
your you reduced your budget because you
didn't have to feed as many people he
didn't have to to pay as many people all
that sort of thing I just needed our
main actress Linnea to commit to the
whole time and and it's hard to ask a
bunch of people to commit the you know 4
12 13 14 days of their life but it's
really easy to ask somebody commit to
one or two days almost anybody will do
that so
working on a low-budget film we're
dealing with very small crew and
everyone is serving multiple roles the
director himself he was directing he was
doing wardrobe he was he was doing food
he was doing all sorts of things I
myself I I worked AC gaffing sound
boompole operating and also acted in one
of the scenes of the film and it's it's
important to be flexible in what you're
willing to do in a low-budget film
because really that's what everybody is
doing we're all working together to try
to make a full feature in a very limited
amount of time
well I think for your main and
characters the ones that are going to
have a lot of speaking time you need to
find people that are gonna memorize
their lines beforehand when you deal
with theater everyone needs to have
their lines memorize there's no mistakes
you're gonna be in front of a live
audience when you're dealing with movies
a lot of people are like oh I'll learn
my lines you know right before we get
started but when you're on a small
budget a time is money like incredibly
so you can't waste any time you only
have you know five hours in this one
location everybody better know their
lines so it is extremely important to do
I'd say do as much prep work as possible
prep work number one do table reads make
sure everyone sits down and you can tell
if they've know their lives or not and
if they don't you need to take them
aside and say memorize those lines
before we get on set because if not
we're not gonna be get this movie made
feeding people's number one if you don't
feed people they're not happy you know I
made sure that like some of the cast and
crew had certain dietary needs I made
sure that those dietary needs were met
you know some people were vegetarians
some people couldn't eat you know
gluten or something I tried to make sure
as much as possible to have foods that
they could eat on set uh when I first
started I was gonna like we planned out
meals with my mom and my sister because
they were helping out behind the scenes
and they were gonna cook everyday and
then what logistically once we got down
to doing it it was just not gonna happen
because things just get crazy
so I found a grocery store that that
basically does like catered food
everyday that has it out you know for
you just to pick up you know sushi and
sandwiches and pizza and all sorts of
you know fruit trays and veggie trays
and so I felt like that was easy a hand
like just little hand foods that they
can pick up people can eat while they
work
I think one of the essentials of being
working in a collaborative environment
is to be nice you know there's plenty of
people that that are hard noses when
they're you know trying to collaborate
with people so I can get their art just
right and that's great maybe that maybe
they make better art but that's not
somebody I want to be and the thing is
is when you're working on a small budget
that's not something you can afford to
be because you could make that first
film with only a few thousand dollars
and maybe you get enough people to work
with it you'll never have those people
want to work with you ever again maybe
you might not ever be able to make
another movie again
so being nice is is huge and also of
being willing when you're when you are
nice you also have to be willing to
collaborate being willing to make
changes because you're working with a
bunch of other artists you're not
working with a bunch of other worker
drones you're working with a bunch of
other people that are artists as well
and they want to insert their art into
what you're doing so yeah you have to be
nice you have to also just be I think
just being a nice person is huge looking
out for they for the emotions of others
not just kind of railroading everyone to
get your way so yeah being nice is huge
a lot of people would say you every have
everybody bring their wardrobe and
that's something you can do but I think
that's kind of a thing that a lot of
independent films are doing right now
and everything kind of like looks all
the same and so one thing we decided to
do was see what resources we had in the
local community I have a friend that
owns a thrift store that owns like kind
of a vintage clothing store so I went to
her and I said can we rent out clothes
and she let us use her places kind of a
dressing room we had a bunch of the
actors come we found the clothes that
looked cool on them and and we and we
actually had kind of like something that
a lot of small budget films don't have
we set it ourselves apart by having like
vintage clothing which looks really cool
on camera and when we went to props you
know eBay Amazon those were huge we had
a whole like costume party and I went to
ebay and went to Amazon and just found
the cheapest mask that looked cool still
and so we we were able to dress
everybody for like about you know five
to ten dollars a person and it all look
like cool costumes look like fun
costumes and and so I think it's
important to to look at like Craigslist
look at Amazon look at eBay you can find
all sorts of cool stuff if you dig
enough you'd sit down and spend a couple
days digging through the internet you
can find cheap stuff and it'll raise
your production value with little money
from a DP standpoint the one thing that
I wanted to do with this knowing that we
only had 13 days to do 90 pages was the
simple rule kiss keep it simple stupid
so we're how do I shoot this as simple
as possible I mean I lit the entire
movie with two one by LEDs and that was
it walk into a room you open a window
you turn on a practical and say great
how does this fit the scene do we need
it more moody do we need a little more
ambience and you just accent from there
and it really helps doing that because
you don't have to worry about moving in
tons of lights or worrying about
different grip trucks and it would have
been nice to have more equipment to do
different things but there is no way we
would have been able to move as quickly
as we did with the amount of people that
we had we were limited to I had one AC
and there was a one guy in sound who
also kind of acted as an AC so having
everyone be as flexible as possible you
you just don't have the time to move all
kind of lights to do different things
and using what you have is probably the
most important thing you can do as a DP
not having to rely on oh I need this
light this is my favorite setup this is
my favorite this what do you have in
front of you make it work
I believe in low-budget magic I think
that a lot of films benefit heavily from
having a lower budget because it forces
all the people working on the film to be
more creative like it forces the forces
the the cinematographer to try to find
creative ways of telling a story
efficiently it forces the editor myself
to try to piece together this thing in a
way that that is interesting and
rhythmic but with very with a small
amount of tools so it definitely makes
for a more creative and rewarding
experience
shooting in 4k was something we knew we
absolutely had to do because there were
a lot of scenes that required push ins
that required dolly slides and whatnot
and we did not have a time to set up any
of this I mean there was one specific
scene that is almost three and a half
minutes of a slow pushing that goes from
a medium Y to a close-up on Linnaeus
face and the only way to do that
consistently is either having some kind
of motion tracker with someone who is
amazing pulling focus using a camera
autofocus which we didn't have or doing
it in post and that's really what we did
for a lot of this was we shoot wide we
push in and post because we know we're
going for a 1080p master
so we have that flexibility to move the
image around to reframe to do the push
ins we just wouldn't have been able to
finish the movie on time had we had to
move around all this equipment so
shooting in 4k and editing in 1080
really made a major difference in the
effectiveness of what we got done
one of the most important things I think
you can also do is find people that
you've worked with in the past that you
know you can work with efficiently and
this is I had Alex and Joseph working
with me just about every single day of
the thirteen days and I'd worked with
them for years in the past just through
different gigs to weddings interviews
you know documentary work whatever we
have a workflow to where we know we need
to swap a lens this crab you know this
person grabs lens this person does this
person does this and there's a workflow
of instead of taking an extra minute to
get here you're shaving a minute off of
everything you do or 30 seconds off of
everything you do that adds up at the
end of the day and you may have saved 20
minutes at the end of the day which
means we could have had an extra 20
minutes to get this shot to finish this
scene which we wouldn't have had had
there not been that working relationship
there
I know a lot of people are always
wanting to shoot on the latest and
greatest equipment the newest things how
do we get this how do we get that and
for us this really came down to what
equipment do we have how are we gonna
work with what we have no I have an F s
Evan and the Sigma art lens package that
I use for just about everything through
my own personal work so instead of
worrying about trying to go through and
get a read getting Alexa you know go six
K go 8 K it was know what do we have
available we only have $8,000 and I
think Joe said 4,000 of that went to
food which does not leave a lot for
everything else and realistically there
are more important things wardrobe is
more important than your camera making
sure you have food or is more important
than your camera so learning to work
with what you have even if you don't
have your own camera find someone that
has one you can use they're going to be
people who just want to create and
finding those people bring them onto
your project regardless of what they're
doing is this is a great way you build
more relationships and you're able just
to create things we may not have been
able to create before
looking for cheaper ways to do something
isn't necessarily always a bad thing I
know one of the things that Joe really
wanted to do was reference a movie
Suspiria in the visual style of how we
shot this and there are so many colored
life there are gels on everything and
the movie is basically yellow red green
blue on every single shot and we just
did not have the amount of lights to do
that so what I did was we found some
super cheap gels off of Amazon for like
12 bucks cut them into little squares
and just stuck them on to the front of
the lens so we had a consistent color
throughout that we would not have been
able to do it any other way without
paying 800 bucks for a filter to go in
front of here or gelling something for
hundreds of more dollars which we just
did not have so there's always a way to
do it
cheaper and that doesn't always mean
it's bad yeah I may have lost a little
bit of clarity because we're putting
crappy plastic in front of the lens but
it worked for the scene
one of the most important things for me
on this film was doing it efficiently
and the most helpful thing other than
weddings was I was able to DP the year
before this a murder-mystery kind of
Recreation show so basically the way
this worked I would show up to set the
director would hand us a script and say
great we have 12 hours here are 40
scenes let's shoot I'm in locations I'd
never seen before
actors I'd never worked with scripts
that I had no idea what we were doing
and doing that for such an extended
period of time kind of builds your mind
where you get to a place you walk into a
room and you're placing cameras you know
you walk into the grocery store you walk
into your bedroom you like I'm going to
shoot this scene this way even it even
if there's no scene so you basically get
to a point where you're living your life
as if you are creating a movie and I
think that's one of the most important
parts for always being able to continue
to be creative because every new room
you walk into is a new set for you so if
you look at it that way you're always
making movies
you